Getting to where we are familiar with
the language, with the intonation, with
the pronunciation, with the word choices.
This is all part of learning language.
It's all part of our brains
getting used to the language.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and
today, I want to talk a little
philosophically about language learning.
I want to talk about how we
get to know a language, how
we become familiar with them.
Uh, not necessarily how we learn
the language, because that's a
big part of learning the language.
So remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, um, click
on the bell for notifications.
And of course, if you follow
me on, uh, any of the podcast,
um, websites, then please leave
a re uh, you know, uh, review.
So, you know, I like to talk
here about language learning.
I know that many of my videos are
used by people who are learning
Enlgish so I try to speak clearly.
Uh, I think my Canadian accent is a
somewhat neutral, so it's probably
easy for people to understand.
And I talk about language learning
because I want to encourage
people to learn languages.
And I want to sort of, uh, make language
learning seem less of a difficult thing.
Uh, I think if you follow these
videos, you'll know that I sort of,
um, encourage people to treat language
learning as sort of a natural activity.
Something that if we put in
enough time, we will improve.
Uh, we don't have to get everything right.
We don't have to get a big, you
know, a high score on the test.
As I do try to avoid tests,
try to avoid drills exercises,
try to just learn the language.
And a big part of that is this sense of
becoming familiar with the language so
that the language becomes like a friend.
So you get to know the language,
just like you get to know, you
get very familiar with people
in your family, familiar family.
You get to know your friends, you
get to know their characteristics.
Um, when you see them.
You know how they behave, you
know, what their character is like.
So you become very sort of
intimately connected with them.
And I feel the same way with
the languages that I've learned.
Uh, maybe it's because
I do a lot of listening.
So, you know, I'm not deliberately trying
to learn anything I do when I'm, you know,
after listening, I review it on my iPad
and look at words and stuff, but I'm not
deliberately trying to learn anything.
I'm more trying to become friends with
the language I'm trying to start to
get in the mood to enjoy the language.
And I think that helps in terms of
pronunciation, for example, in terms
of intonation, in terms of using the
right phrase, Uh, as we start to become
familiar with the language, even if
we don't fully understand it, a lot of
these things are kind of penetrating us.
I noticed this in my Arabic and my,
and my Persian, uh, not paradoxically.
And remember, again, that many of you are
studying languages at school, or you may
be studying them for professional reasons,
which was my case when I was learning
Chinese 50 years ago, that was my job.
I was doing it seven hours a day,
but now I'm doing it as a hobby.
I'm doing it out of interest.
I'm doing it because I'm interested,
not only in the language, but in
the history and the culture behind
that language and possibly travel
and food and meeting people.
And that whole sense of being able to
participate in another cultural media.
So that's what motivates me.
And what I found recently is that my
strategy of, you know, and, and this
is this whole issue of studying more
than one language, say two languages
at the same time, you know, what's
the best way to combine languages.
Should we be doing two languages
the same day or alternating days?
And I'm beginning to find that if I
go one week on one and one week on the
other, then when I come back to the first
one, I'm sort of reconnecting with an
old friend and that's a nice feeling.
And I mean, even finding, and
as I said before, this is a
business of benign neglect.
If you leave one language, go to the other
one for awhile, come back to the first
one, all of a sudden things are clearer.
Um, maybe because you've pushed your
brain to work this other language.
And maybe because if we stay with
the one language and we're trying
to learn and we're disappointed that
we're not doing better in a certain
way, frustration, creeps, creeps in.
Whereas if we leave it for awhile, do
this other language and then we come
back to the first one we rediscover an
old friend, everything is fresh again.
And I do find that I
hear things more clearly.
Uh, I I'm a little more aware of, of,
of the language and getting to where
we are familiar with the language, with
the intonation, with the pronunciation.
Word choices.
This is all part of learning language.
It's all part of our brains
getting used to that language.
And if we can develop this sort of
natural, getting to know the language,
we're going to speak more naturally, as
opposed to trying to learn it through
rules and tests and things of that nature.
And it's surprising.
I was, uh, I spent a while
with, with, uh, Persian.
Then I started listening to my,
um, Arabic, uh, podcast again.
And I find that, you know, I recognize
my old friend, I recognize some of
the personality of the Arab speaker.
He's sort of very intent on getting
his view across and he uses certain
expressions in a, uh, certainly in
the, uh, in the standard Arabic,
which I'm listening to from, you
know, these political podcasts.
Uh, the Egyptian Arabic has a different
personality and I have a very good tutor
who's creating content for me in Egypt.
And so I can get familiar with and
get to know and get to feel the
personality of Egyptian Arabic.
And then I'll leave that and
then I'll go to my Persian again.
And on each of these occasions,
it's staying fresh for me.
And then I'm rediscovering an old friend.
Picking up where we left off and I find
that I'm progressing perhaps or enjoying
it more or less frustrated by my lack
of progress and more aware that I am
becoming more familiar with the language.
It's becoming more familiar to me.
It's becoming more of a friend to me.
I'm recognizing characteristics.
Therefore intonation,
pronunciation, turns of phrases.
And in that way, the language
is gradually penetrating.
And this normally, and I found this
when, after an absence, I started
speaking again with, with my tutor, all
of a sudden, all of this familiarity,
this comfort level with the language
as being, you know, converts itself
into being able to speak more fleet
freely and speak more, I wouldn't say
fluently yet in those languages, but
more comfortably in those languages.
So, you know, learning languages
is not just learning the rules,
although it can help to review the
basic patterns of the language.
It's it's becoming, you know, emotionally
connected to the language, becoming
more familiar with the language,
making the language your friend.
So I find a strategy of alternating
languages works for me, but some
people may prefer to stay with
one language, but ultimately we
want to sort of get that language.
And so I think learning language includes
this sense of making these languages
your friend, making them familiar to you.
So a little bit of a vague thought,
but it's something that's been running
around and in my mind, and I'd be
interested in, in any reaction.
Maybe what I had to say there
is, is just a lot of nonsense.
I don't know.
Anyway, thanks for listening.